en fait je crois que c'est c'est ma part
de vérité arithmétique manquent pas
possible qu'elle soit président de la
république et politiquement encore moins
arithmétiquement parce que quand on a
pas ni sa nièce ni de villiers ni ménard
qui sont quand même un moment donné des
gens qui devrait lui fournir des
réserves de voix de ceux qui ne voteront
pas pour vous et il l'affiché qui le
disent
ça veut dire que vous n'êtes même pas
capable de fédérer dans votre camp qui
est celui effectivement du rassemblement
national dont je ne la voit pas en
capacité de gagner sur le bairi
arithmétique parce qu'on sait très bien
que pour gagner une élection
présidentielle fallu au delà de sa
famille politique est elle aujourd'hui
il est en difficulté au sein même de sa
famille politique
ça c'est le premier point politiquement
parce que je crois en la france je crois
aux français je pense qu'il ya une
majorité de français qui aiment notre
pays et quand on aime notre pays on ne
peut pas donner des clés de la maison de
france à marine le pen
ça n'est pas possible ça n'est pas
envisageable
et ça n'enlèvera en rien les souffrances
de ceux qui votent marine le pen ça
n'arrive à rien les problématiques qui
n'ont pas été réglés par la droite et la
gauche au pouvoir parce que je vais vous
dire une chose
moi j'ai toujours voté à gauche mais
avant de diaboliser marine le pen
je demande à ce que chacune et chacune
balayant devant la porte de ceux pour
lesquels nous avons voté quand on a
aujourd'hui les programmes ticona dans
nos banlieues de ghettoïsation
d'assignation à résidence
donc je fais de mal être et de mal vivre
qui a mis en place et que moi je suis
content marine le pen contre son projet
politique
mais j'ai le courage de dire que ceux
qui l'ont mis en place tout ça c'est des
gens qui étaient censés être républicain
c'était ce qui ce qui était censé porter
un vivre ensemble à la française et qui
n'ont pas été à la hauteur donc cela moi
je ne leur donne pas aujourd'hui la
situation et je l'ump qui est république
est aujourd'hui là ils ont eu leur
chance ils ont été aux responsabilités
exactes
ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas carrément
leur pc il ya eric naulleau qui doit
prendre l'antenne aller c'est vraiment
celle qui allie donc non pour me marie
le pen ne sera pas présidente parce que
même si
elle rassemble au premier tour la marque
le pen est totalement un boulet pour
second et elle ne s'est pas l'assemblée
les français rassemble que son camp
deuxièmement elle n'en a pas assez envie
quand on n'a pas envie se présente par
ne veut pas y aller c'est celui qui fut
celle qui a le plus envie qui gagnera
dernière chose par rapport à ce qu'elle
dit annie stoner qui m'a vraiment
choquée créneau marine le pen la
présidente continue à réagir quand il a
dit qu'il avait des territoires perdus
des sommes donnant droit à faire mais
non et à se boucher le nez savait que ce
déni généralisé en france que justement
le rassemblement national samedi apprend
les vrais problèmes et créent de
l'audience donc si vous voulez battre le
front national leur action nationale où
les le pen ne criait pas que yanis dit
quelque chose vraie ya des territoires
perdus depuis des années lisez le
bouquin de barbara le fait vous verrez
il ya des zones de non-droit on y adhère
force de nier cela c'est comme ça qu'on
fait le lit ligne assure le mot
nationale bombe surtout bonne déni c'est
soyons enfin républicain et regardons
les vrais pros le monde